It'll be saved so we can listen to it. So if anybody is people will be jumping on and jumping off as usual, if you
Are afraid to have your voice recorded. Please don't be but
It's then you could ask me a question via the chat
So feel free to do that. I do have some other questions that people other people have asked me to go over this time
So hopefully I'll get to all those
All right, so we're gonna jump in and we're gonna
Get started today. So today we're gonna be talking about the genetics and what we're gonna be looking for on your genetics
And what are the main pieces?
There's no way I'll be able to get through this and the time that we have a lot of but we're gonna get started at the next week
We'll go over some more things
But I look at somebody's genetics. There's different pieces that we could look at
We could do a supplement report and it lay out some specific supplements based upon that person's genetics
And we could do a gene analysis and then that's what I look at when I'm looking at some specific genes for that patient
And it pulls up all the genes that 23 and me has has run on that patient
So that's what we're going to
Get into the cancer genes and there's certain cancer genes that we'll look at like the
The P53 genes and the m-tore genes and the K-ROS genes
So let's just look up that and so you can see what we're looking at
So the K-ROS pathway is a pathway for that supposed to inhibit cancer
So there are certain genes that are called tumor suppressor genes
That think of your inside the cell as as
The amount of information that's taking place inside your cell is like the amount of information that takes place inside New York City
So there's a lot of chaos. There's a lot of things going on a lot of planned activity
But things that could break up plan activity inside the cell are toxic exposure
Infections
Anything that gets inside that cell that could that could wreak
Chaos could cause problems to happen. Well
When God created us he knew that that was going to take place
So in each of us we have these protective
genes called tumor suppressor genes
And there's probably more research done on the tumor suppressor genes than on any of the genes and
And I look up all those tumor suppressor genes. So the K-ROS pathway is one tumor suppressor pathway
So think of a tumor suppressor gene pathway as
If something wreaks chaos and instead of that nucleus the DNA and the nucleus telling the cell to replicate
once every 12 weeks and then having the mother cell die
um
It starts replicating once a day
That by definition is cancer
So cancer is a cell
replicating at a
Rapid rate or at a rate much more rapid than what it's supposed to replicate at
So if a colon cell is supposed to replicate about once every 12 weeks
And the mother cell goes through apoptosis it dies and then the baby cell
Becomes an adult and it does its job for 12 weeks and it replicates itself and the mother cell dies
And that process goes on through life. That's what aging really is
Is that you know as we continue to replicate now. I'm 57 years old. How many times has
By colon cell replicated well
It replicates every 12 weeks. That's about four times a year
So four times 50 it's replicated 200 times. There's a chance that that cell isn't going to be quite as healthy as when it replicated twice
So that's really what aging is
So the things that affect
aging and a person aged better than another person is how well they took care of themselves. So
You're replicating a less degenerative cell that if I was drinking and smoking and
Doing bad stuff to my body
I'm going to replicate a more degenerative cell and now the mother cell of the next replication is starting off at a lower point
Follow me
But that's aging what we're talking about with cancer is if something gets in there and changes the replication cycle
So now the rate of replication
Is you know
daily
Now we have kids are going on if that takes place you have certain gene systems called tumor suppressor genes that are supposed to kick out and go
Whoa, what's going on? Why are we replicating so quickly? We need to turn on the apoptosis pathway
In each cell there is certain pathways or what are called that stimulate
Capsaces that stimulate apoptosis or cell death
So it's supposed to kill the cell that's rapidly replicating
Um, and if the k-ros pathway and
Uh, TP53 pathway are certain
um
tumor suppressor pathways
There's more the p10 pathway and we want to look at all those
So let's say on this pathway the p10 pathway on this sample patient
This person actually had as a cancer patient and they're p10 pathway
They have a single leal variant so if you have not looked at any of my genetic videos
I challenge you to do though do that because when we look at the variants or what I call defects
We will see a zero or a blank that means the person has no defect on that gene. That's really good
Uh, there'll be a one that means they have a single leal defect or a heterozygous defect or they'll have a two
A double leal defect or a homozygous defect or that's the worst that you could get because you inherited a gene
From your mother and you inherited one from your father
That's where you have two alleles to each gene and
If one of them was defective, let's say from your mother then you'll have a single leal defect like this person does
They have a one and a one and a one of these three genes
So what do we look at genes? We're looking at families of genes. So this p10
groupied of five p10 genes that 23 me reads out is um is um
Is a family of tumor suppressor genes
So if this person has three defective tumor suppressor genes of the p10 gene pathway
Then we want to look at other factors. Well, how common is this single leal defect?
Well, it's not very commonly 18.5% of the people have this gene
defect right here a single leal defect
This this person had a two here that would be really really uncommon and this this
This graph part of the graph here has to do it of the
We have currently 23,143 patients in this system
So and these are all 23,143
Not very healthy people
So this isn't a this isn't a cohort of a study of healthy individuals
This is a cohort of study of people that have chronic Lyme autoimmune diseases of cancer
And some people that were healthy that just wanted to get their genetics done like family members of patients etc
But the majority of these are not
You know real well people at the time that they got their genetics done. So
um
having you know
This there is some significance dead to having a what of this gene
Maybe a little bit less significance to this deep gene defect because half the population half that
Follow me. So that's part of how I factor in the significance of this gene because if we look up the research of this specific p10 gene
There's gonna be probably nothing
That's published
That's pretty odd because if you looked up research on let's say gluten sensitivity
There's probably at this point to time 10,000 published articles and we're talking about
Published peer reviewed articles
And would you have none on there? This is this is the infancy that genetic testing is in
so
Well, you know, we're really at a cutting edge of this now
If I think there's some significance of this these three p10 gene defects that I and personally
I would say oh not convinced that there's a huge significance
I've done the research on p10 genes in
general and the
Intervention that is shown in the research that I've looked at and all the p10 genes would be to add make sure we're adding
Curcumin to this don't remember that but I'm just giving you an example of how we would look at your
Oh, we have let's say if they had a one and one and a two and a one and a one there would be definitely
Significance to those defects for that individual and we would really bump up their curcumin curcumin is the active product of turmeric
So decreasing inflammation would be important and I just picked this one out of the bunch here
So let's look at the p53 genes of this person. Oh look at their p53 genes pretty darn good, huh
One single allele defect
None of these other ones have defects, but then you look at oh wow look at that most of them don't have any defects
But then you look at the oddity of this particular gene. Oh
My gosh
This gene almost nobody
97.4% of the population of our 23,000 do not have a defect on this gene and this person does have a defect
So even though their p53 genes look miraculous, right
This is a pretty significant defect
So the p53 genes are again are another family of tumor suppressor genes
And it this actually the p53 genes are probably the most studied genes because this was the first tumor suppressor gene
That was ever discovered
So um not that you need to know that but it's interesting for
People like me, but there are significant intervention steps that a person would want to use
With that and
And I won't go over them right now, but then we would recommend oh, we're gonna get on green t extract
Because that would be one of the intervention steps with this one
So with this person, I actually did put them on
Oh green t extract and a few other things because of this
Um, is it such an uncombed defect?
Follow me
And so that's what we look at when we look at a person's
Genes these different pathways on a k-ros pathway
I think we just discussed that a little bit ago. There's just another tumor suppressor pathway
So our goals are all the different tumor suppressor pathways. There's other pathways that you could look at
Like the that are fun to look at
Like the BDNF pathway
This is it is less
Cancer gene, but this is the BDNF is a gene that stands for that actually makes a enzyme that's called brain derived neurotropic factor
That's what BDNF stands for
But it's a it's a very important gene if you don't want to get Alzheimer's and dementia
So looking at this gene even though oh, I got cancer. I'm trying to deal with cancer. It
Brain derived neurotropic factor really helps with other things that we're dealing with too
So although I want you know a patient may come to me for cancer or alive or something we do want to take as
You know a you know a big of view. I don't want to be biopic and say okay
Well, we're only going to treat your cancer because
First of all it goes against my belief system that we're treating the patient anyhow and
the more
inclusive you could be
From every aspect including genetics the better results you're going to have
This person I would definitely you know use some intervention to help that because brain derived neurotropic factor is essential for neurons to heal
So this can be a factor with brain cancer. This can be a factor with other cancers that can metastasize to the brain
Which are a lot of them
So
You could tie it back to cancer
It's really really important to have healthy brain derived or profit factor production if you want your neurons to stay healthy
Because you're always going to be damaging the runs and you need them to heal just like every other cell
Okay, so those are some of the genes that we look at but we're looking at cancer genes that are in the reports here because
You know, I'm the only person that's really looking at genes from a cancer standpoint of like colleagues
The other reports that we'll look at are
The different steps that and steps are are the gene
Pieces that we're looking at the polymorphisms. So the other variants or defects that we'll look at are in
um
looking at gluten issues and
uh
caffeine metabolism whether the person should be drinking coffee and I have videos on all these things going through
Somebody's report like this. I'm not going to go into an adept here
But there's some very important genes that are tied to cancer with this
So this is how you're got heals right here the BCMO genes and the FUT2 genes
That it's um, it's been a rare that I've ever had a cancer patient that didn't have
Significant about a FUT2 gene defects. Oh, that's why literally I think I put almost every cancer patient on sunscreen
Because that would be the intervention for the BCMO and the FUT2 genes and here's another example of a person with
considerable moment defects and then we can't use this little piece you can't do this if I
If I load this is a PDF and set it to you, but in my software we could look at where the meat of the population is
um as far as the amount of defects and where the client is where the patient is where you are for looking at yours
in um in comparison
It's a nice little handy tool
Because remember we're not looking at a healthy cohort of population of groups
So really if we were looking at a healthy cohort the meat would be somewhere to the left here
And I tell people as I go through their genes as we look at them
We really want you to be to the left of the meat
So when you're to the right of the meat, this is not really good because
These are not necessarily real healthy people and you're worse than they are
So that's not where we want to be
So in this client definitely the BCMO gene which has to do with
Ability to use made a carotene and heal epithelial tissue which that is part of your goddess epithelial tissue
It's always skin so it's the lighting of your lungs
So are the lighting of your blood vessels so this is really important for cardiac patients
That their BCMO gene so
Though I mainly deal with cancer patients and some live patients
You could really help patients with all sorts of different disease processes
And even more importantly if the world was a perfect place you could help people prevent
Cardio issues by looking at their genes and a lot of other issues by looking at their genes
So it could be extremely beneficial for
What do you start looking at this you go? Oh my gosh. I got to get my daughter's genes out of my sons and my husband's mom
Really a smart idea to do that. So
All right talking too much
But we want to look at the gut line the ability for the gut to heal
Histamine is another big piece that we want to look at with
Cancer patients this person is really good. They have no problem breaking down histamine in their gut
That would be the ABP1 gene up here
And they really don't have much of a problem
I'm sure they're probably to the left of the meat here. Yes, they are see
Breaking down histamine in the tissue
So that this ancient empty gene breaks down histamine in the tissue
This breaks down histamine in the gut
Then you could find some rather really interesting stuff these two gene this gene families two gene families here have a lot to do
With your ability to break down oxalates in the gut and this person looks pretty good
Though this gene this top one carries a little bit more weight. So they're
Still they're the left of the meat there
but
People that have a lot of gene defects in here, which I would not say this person does
Is going to have a much greater risk for kidney stones because they'll absorb the oxalates
They'll settle in the kidney collect calcium and you have a calcium oxalate crystal
Then we'll look at some other genes that have to do with mitochondrial function in ability for mitochondria to produce energy
This has to do this plays a part of peace to what we would do for a patient for their cancer diet
So does I didn't get into that with
tumors suppressor genes but actually created some videos about that they're on the Facebook page
Make sure if you're not on that you get on that too because I post some new stuff on there
every week
But this plays into what diet a person should be on
person with the amount of cartotene defects that they have here and the acat defects gives us some hints that
They're not utilizing fatty acids in the cell very well for energy and they're probably
Going to their cancer gives us one hit that the cancer is probably feeding off of the end point of glycolysis
Not to get too technical but then in that case we put about a more ketogenic like diet
There's other hints that we look at and I balance out all of those so
But just looking at this I can't remember what we saw on this person the rest of their things but
um
This person would be already a one strike for a ketogenic like diet
And then we go through there's just you can see we're only
Fourth of the way down this page the detox pathways
There's just tons and tons and stuff that we want to look at with that
Because if you can detoxify very quickly if you're a slow detoxer you're going to be more apt
To not detox and and then the cells have to store things so think of it this way
So you're exposed to pesticide that pesticide goes into your body
picked up by the let's say it was on your hands. Let's say you breed that in okay more commonly
Or if you ate it you absorbed it
It goes into your bloodstream eventually gets to your bloodstream and your liver is supposed to detoxify it
So let's go down to the pathway that would detoxify pesticides which would be this pathway right
Here this pond pathway and out this person
Uh really sticks up that so look at how bad they are at detoxified pesticides insecticides
And this is also the pathway that you detox vaccinations
Um, so oh that's not good
So exposure to pesticides circulated through their blood going to their liver
Let's say they had a perfectly healthy liver other than this
genetic pathway defect
Because they didn't drink didn't smoke they ate perfectly they were
A normal way they took care of themselves
And pretend they had a perfect liver which is not the case for anybody period
And they have these pathway defects they are not going to be able to detoxify pesticides insecticides
Vaccines large chemicals like that
Very fast and all so then it doesn't get detoxified so it circulates through the blood again to go through the liver again
Circulates again to go through their liver again
And eventually it's going to be pushed into the cells
And it'll be pushed into the cells which are more highly a vascular which where are those
Around your organs
So and it'll go into the fat cells around your organs and in the organs
Um think of fat cells as having the spiritual gift of accommodation
They are they just welcome anybody in there
So they store things
So that talks it is stored in there and the bad thing is is
That it could affect
Metabolic pathways
So if it affects the replication pathway in the cell starts replicating
This person has cancer that's caused from that pesticide
The following so that's how it works. So
It's really not
A whole lot more complicated than that unless you really want to get into the pathway that is being affected by that pesticide
So if that person
Either a wasn't exposed to any pesticide so that it ever got into his blood to have to be detoxified
Through this defective pathway that this person has
Or if the person didn't have these defects
Um, they'd have a much less risk of
Ever developing cancer
Um, so
A person can so you look at their detoxification pathways
You could say you're going to be at high let's say they don't have cancer
This is a seven-year-old kid here. I would say your child is going to be at a much higher risk
Of problems
Could be cancer could be all sorts of things
Because they are going to be a slow detoxer
Of whatever that pathway detoxes
So you're going to be a slow detoxer of in this person's case of pesticides and pesticides chemicals
You just are like it's your genes. You're not going to be a fast detoxer of those things
So it'd be really wise if you stay away from them
The problem is when you start talking about okay, I'll stay away from pesticides
Well, I won't use them in my house. I won't spray for bugs. I won't have my house
Bob, I won't
Write all those things are good things to do even if you had a perfect pathway here
Um, but you can't get away from them. You know if you're not doing it your neighbor is
So, um, it's it's everywhere. It's that's the bad thing
Is that you can do everything right and you can still be exposed to bad things
Um, we live in a
In a fallen world. I guess so but knowing that knowing this piece can be extremely helpful
So I'm going to choose not to vaccinate. I'm not going to get the flu shot
Because I know my pond pathway. I am if this person got so you look what I look for
Should a person vaccinate their child? This is one of the pathways I look for. Well, let's look at their pond pathway
And let's look at their mthfr pathway. This person's got out of the two mthfr genes
This one would be the most important one this bottom one, but this one they have a two one
So if this was if this was a
Two-month-old child or let's say this was the mother who's going to have a baby in what's no if they should vaccinate their child
Well, you're you're probably going to pass a number of these genes off to your
To your baby we also should look at your spouses the baby's fathers
Jeans and then you could really extrapolate what the baby's genes are going to be
um
And your child's going to at least have a one there even if you have the father had a blake and a blake
I would say no way I would have vaccinate my child. Well
Personally, I would vaccinate my child even if I had no gene defects here because
This is not a talkable vaccination to talk about that another time, but it's
Absolutely, this would be a setup for a possible
autism
for a child to be
vaccinated with a gene if this was the child's genes this would be
Prime for autism. Now why are all doctors doing this and look at evaluated this and make it a decision whether to vaccinate based upon their genes
I don't know
Here's another important gene that I talk about in a lot of my videos because it is a really important one this
ABP1 gene is important because this is the single pathway that you detoxify
insats, duds, or anti-inflammatory drugs and there's 15,000 people a year that drop dead of Tylenol poison in the
Dead States alone per year 15,000
Okay, I'll guarantee you that probably 99% of them have a two here
So this person does not have a two here so this person
Could theoretically take Tylenol and don't have it really
Have a toxic relic reaction to it because they could detoxify it fairly rapidly
But if you have a one here then you probably should take it more than a couple times a month
If you have a two here, you probably should take it more than a few times a year
If you could help it
Problem is is that one of this person has chronic pain. Well, then you got to use some other things to deal with chronic pain
Okay, so is that giving you some hints on what I'm looking at?
I know I speak quite rapidly and you might have to listen to this again
Less year as dirty as me and you watched a bunch of videos and you would study this
But I'll open it up to some questions because then I want to go beyond our a lot of time
So if you have some questions, please pipe in and let me know
Nothing. Okay, I'm gonna answer some questions and I got
Um
emailed to me then
So one of the questions was on the because on the genes
Um, how do I know if I have to be gluten-free on the genes? So
Here are the genes for gluten these top ones right here
This HLA gene family are for gluten sensitivity in this k i a a family are for
Full celiac
So this person has no celiac genes
But let's say they were even Blake Blake Blake Blake so there were zeros on all the HLA genes
Does that mean the person could eat gluten?
So the answer to that is no
So I do not make assessments on gluten or dairy or other food sensitivities based upon genetics
So if the person's genes look exactly like this person's I would say they have a greater chance for gluten sensitivity
But food sensitivities are not based upon genetics. They're based upon
The body making antibodies against the peptides of the food product
So in gluten's case gluten has
The the sensitivity that people have to gluten is to the protein called gliadid
And gliadid is a giant is a protein so think of a protein as a pearl necklace
Pearl necklace has all these beads
Each bead is an amino acid
So what a protein is is a chain of amino acids in a specific sequence
So gliadid is a chain of amino acids in a specific sequence that we call gliadid
And it's in gluten and it's in
Foods that have gluten in it
so
That
Long chain of amino acids is called gliadid the problem with some of the testing that's out there
As a person will come in to me and go oh no, I don't have gluten problems really how do you know because I had a blood test
Oh, could I see it in the blood test is for
It's a it's a blood draw that tests for antibodies to gliadid that means
gliadid the long chain of amino acids that whole entire pearl necklace had to get across the gut border
Into the blood and that person's immune system had to start created antibodies against that giant pearl necklace
Now in order for the giant pearl necklace to get across the gut border
That person had to have one heck of a damaged gut border. I'll tell you that
Because normally when you eat that pearl necklace when you eat gluten
Not very much of it is broken down in the stomach
But then it goes into the first part of the small intestine
Your pancreas secrete enzymes into the first part of the small intestine in those pancreatic enzymes think of them as
Cisars and they go to those pearl necklaces the protein and they start
Snip it up. Snip, snip, snip, snip, snip, snip, snip, snip, snip so that
The chain of 150 beads gets broken down into a piece of 12 and a piece of 15 and a piece of 27 and a piece of this
And then as it goes through the intestines it gets broken down by enzymes ultimately down to one or two little pearls
And that's what's supposed to go across the gut border
Just one or two little pearls
That's called an amino acid if it's just one. It's not glee added anymore
It's not gluten anymore. It's just that amino acids tyrosine or triptophane or whatever amino acid it is
It's not gluten anymore
Or two, which is called a dipeptide maybe it's tyrosine plus triptophane
That's the only size that should cross the gut border
So most people that have gluten sensitivities will test negative for a glee added blood test because you had to have one
enormously damaged gut to have the entire chain of beads get across it
I mean, you'd like drive it a semi through your gut
But some people have such a damaged gut that it wouldn't show positive for antibodies to glee added
That's how bad their gut is
So the proper test
For gluten sensitivity is not a genetic test
It is a test that will test for the peptides the pieces
So as it gets as that giant chain of
Of beads goes into the intestines and the amino acids start cutting it up into chunks of 12 but 15 to 27
Then if your gut is really damaged a chunk of six or a chunk of five or a chunk of 12 could get through
Not a chunk of a 200
But there are there is one lab that tests for these so these chunks of
5 or 12 or 27 are called peptides of glee added
peptide think of pieces of glee added so these peptides can be tested for
So you can develop antibodies to different glee added peptides
So you want to do a test in the early lab that currently does that as a lab called Syrex lab
If you so desired to do a test for gluten for gluten sensitivity which I don't
hardly ever do that anymore because you just don't need to
But if you wanted to prove that you really shouldn't eat gluten you run a Syrex test
And you could test for that a test for the peptides
Follow me so
That's why when I look at somebody's genetic report we typically skip this piece because that's not really important to me
That's not what's going to tell me we should not eat gluten
And then secondly we're talking about dealing with any product disorder of any kind
Gluten even if you don't have sensitivity to it. It's going to be inflammatory
So you actually have you actually have neurons eat your gut that fire directly to the brain
They're called gluteal morpheid receptors
So gluten could attach to these receptors in the gut
We'll fire stimulation to the brain the same as morpheid
That's a good
So
Really honestly there is an any human being that really should be eating gluten
It's just not good for us
So are there some people that let's say they did a Syrex test and a test negative they don't have any antibodies could they have some gluten sure
They could have some gluten though and then is it good for them? No
So it's kind of like in those cases is alcohol okay to drink once in a while sure
I think it's fine to drink you know once a month or something like that is it fine to drink once a day no
It fits into that category in my mind set
So even if you don't have any gluten glianned antibodies any of the peptide antibodies should you be eating gluten no
So inflammatory you don't need any of that chronic inflammation
Chronic inflammation isn't good for us
All right does that help answer some questions there the same thing we'd look at with k-sine which is the dairy
Now this genetic test is MC
M6 is for lactose I don't care about lactose we care about case the protein in dairy which is k-sine
But this peanut allergy what it's kind of fun to look at because like this first it has
Very very low risk of developing the peanut allergy, but I've had people with a two at a two here and they go
I don't have a peanut allergy. Well if those genes really turn on
You could go into a full-blown IgE reaction probably not a good idea to eat a lot of peanuts
Probably not a good idea for anybody to eat a lot of peanuts anyhow peanuts are very high in mycotoxins
You're better off switching to an almond butter or cashew butter or something like that if you are eating a peanut butter
The caffeine metabolism has to do with
You're how fast rapidly you
metabolize caffeine if you have a two here you metabolize it
Quite quickly which can be good or bad. I mean, so you could drink coffee
You metabolize it get rid of it really easy
But you won't have any the ill effects of caffeine for a long period of time people have a zero here probably shouldn't drink much coffee at all
Just kind of fun. There's some fun things to look at with your genes and
A lot of things you can tell them what a person looking at their genes, but remember always with your genetics your environment trumps your genes always always always always always so
It's really what happens in your environment that really
basically turns genes out and off
And that's where these defects can really become expressed
so
That's why I say with somebody with pitted allergies if they had a two and a two here
They might not have a pitted allergy here, but if you're going to eat a lot of peanuts and peanut butter
There's a lot of people that are addicted to that
But if they have defects, it's very easy for that gene to become expressed of them to go into a full ige reaction
Which could be deadly
So knowing this gene defect is important, right?
so
That can be helpful
So your environment can cause the expression of a gene defect
and
That's called epigenetics
So helpful so far
Any questions from the group here?
Everybody's afraid to ask a question
That's okay
All right, so that was all the questions I handed by
Portfolio and we're supposed to have another call tomorrow that I moved it to today because I forgot I have to go to the dentist
So
We'll probably have another call
Probably this weekend. I'll post it on Facebook. Make sure you stay
Contact with that because I will be out of town at the
Cancer control society's 45th annual convention. I'm speaking
Got that in Los Angeles this coming weekend
And I'll be in my hotel room and you need to get bored, so I'll probably do another call
All right, so hopefully this is helpful
And we will I'll get this saved and it will be put up on the Facebook page
As a link in it's going to be
An unlisted video
So you will not be able to go to my youtube channel you can't go to my youtube channel and see any of our zoom call
videos
That's what just protects you guys from
um, you know if you do ask questions and these are for our patients
Not for the general public so if we get a lot of people that go to our youtube channel that are not patients
and watch videos
Which is great, but um, these zoom calls are specifically for patients who you could only access it through that link
Um, because it's an unlisted video
All right, thanks so much
And we will be talking again very soon and again if you have any personal questions make sure you call the office of the
Time scheduled with myself or Angie Michelle
All right